I really don't know what's going on but
one of the things that we've spoken
about so much has been online dating
somewhere around between 40 and 60
percent of relationships now begin
online
what are you hearing from women about
their experiences with online dating and
messaging and guys demeanor and what
they're getting right and wrong well I
think that you could
you you could caricature things a little
and say that there's
an enormous number of guys who go to
dating apps for sex
and that it's less likely that on mass
and it depends on age group obviously
but
an age where people tend to start
looking for relationships and women
start to really seriously think about
well I do actually really want a
relationship I'm not saying men don't
get to the same point but
I believe that there's more guys who are
on dating apps just going I'm just here
because I want to hook up
and
that
that I think results in a lot of just
people were just completely misaligned
when they're talking in those places
there's a lot of guys there's a lot of
bad behavior from guys who are hiding
behind the screen we know that
and that's because they're able to do
things that wouldn't that would never
dare do
out there in the world how's that
affecting women
how's that affecting their behavior
their viewers I think it skews their
perception of what guys are actually
like
because
they're getting they're getting that
from a proport a decent proportion of
guys and it's making them think well
there are no there are no decent guys
like this is this is just horrendous
but
there are decent guys
and they may be they may those guys
unfortunately May some of them at least
will feel completely overlooked in those
places but there's an awful lot of women
I think that Come Away with a really
tarnished view of what men are like
and I also think like some for some guys
I mean maybe for all but what they do in
that environment when they feel like no
one is there's no repercussions
I feel like that's indicative of how
they
actually feel about women or how they
you know well that's indicative of their
deeper relationship
with women
because or or in ignorance it could just
be an ignorance too that they're not
educated they've never been taught this
is this is what it's like to be on the
receiving end
of this
like this is what that experience
actually is I don't think most men
actually have any bearing on that when
they're doing it and it's not all men
but the men that do it I think they're
they're not connected to the effects of
that okay so step into the guys who are
struggling with dating online
what should they be doing if they want
to be effective at convincing a girl
that they are in this for the right
reasons that they are a guy of value and
virtue
what should they be doing when they're
texting making an attractive dating
profile communicating backward and
forward
I mean for me I think the ultimate thing
is that there's a sense of
decisiveness when it comes to
progression
you know instead of being the guy that
texts back and forth with someone for
two weeks
and there's plain chicken with like
who's gonna ask who to do something and
actually meet in real life
be the person who actually advances it
I'm not saying
in ways that suddenly make us seem
desperate but
you know you be the person that suggests
getting on the phone or meeting up for a
quick coffee like that that's a pretty
that shows intent it's a good first date
idea
some of the favorite ones
I like anything where you are not
sitting kind of facing each other I
don't I think roller coaster
yeah I remember saying this at an event
and just I go I go you know a good day
is like park bench style like anywhere
where you can sort of face out into the
world and turn to each other when you
want to talk and I just heard a voice in
the crowd go
sushi
[Laughter]
it's like the guy had just like he
couldn't he really got it yeah he was
like he just really connected with as
well that's what I'm gonna do next sushi
yeah it really cracked me up I but you
know anything that I like if you're
gonna go to a restaurant on a date sit
at the bar
hmm it's a much better thing that going
to a table is awkward sitting across
from each other and you're staring at
each other the whole time go sit at the
bar because then you can ex you can chat
with the bartender
you can turn and say something but you
don't have to position your entire body
towards someone but it what it allows to
happen is a more natural kind of you
know if you look at attraction and
seduction it kind of we start facing
away from each other we become aware of
each other like a sort of side eye I'm
aware of you and then eventually we turn
into each other and I think that our
date can almost kind of you've you've
already got the we know each other part
unless you're just approaching someone
out there in the world
but
a date where you can start
pointed at something and the more
Rapport you build and the more comfort
you build you kind of end up turning
inwards that's a pretty good date so
walking is a good date like walking
somewhere with someone I think as a guy
you have to you have to also bear in
mind that for women's safety is a big
thing so being somewhere where they feel
like
where they actually feel safe with you
so not walking in a dark alleyway no no
dark Alleyways except a zero dark
alleyway first date policy okay fine
cool yeah those are those are and also
not
don't be afraid to have a short date
you know if you can lower the stakes for
someone going into a date 30 minute walk
in a coffee yeah like even even you know
I have to be in this part of town later
in the day but I'm you know I'm over
here do you want to meet up for a coffee
like that just says to someone I don't
have to worry I don't have to think
about whether I want to spend an entire
evening with this person right now
the more you can lower the stakes you
only have to think of regular social
interactions if you make a new friend
it's you kind of want to build up to
things because it's hard to hang out
with a new friend it takes effort and
it's not you're kind of you know you
don't have that Comfort where you're
just like let's just hang out on the
sofa for a few hours and just chill like
that but if you say you know let's let's
grab a coffee let's grab a juice
whatever it's and they there's an out
you're more likely to have half an hour
with a new friend and that half hour can
be the making of a new friendship but
you've got to get you know as Sean acre
would put it in the Happiness Advantage
you have to lower the activation energy
required and that can apply for dating
too what have you seen with regards to
online dating profiles
good ones bad ones oh man I'm so not
close to dating profiles
but
for me
show don't tell is an important rule in
dating profiles you know that whenever
we say we're something
would tell if I say I'm like I'm funny
I'm not showing you I'm fine I'm not
saying anything that's funny I'm just
telling you I'm funny or when we're just
saying what we like listing things we
want in a person
like I want someone who's funny that's
it's
it becomes vanilla very quickly because
sort of isn't everybody
I think that real estate is space to
actually show something about your
personality or who the the way that you
think there was a great dating profile
that I once came across
and this woman said it the prompt was
something like what's your
biggest disappointment
and she said that my future kids
will never get the experience of walking
around Blockbuster Video and choosing a
movie for the night
I always thought that was such a great
thing to say
because
that firstly she was showing like that
was endearing it was like a it showed a
nice part of her personality
she also managed to say that she wanted
kids in a completely relaxed way
not don't message me if you don't want
to be serious
like no casual you know when people put
like no casual hookups it's like you
don't need to say that
you you can just somewhat that intention
of yours will announce itself as you
start to talk to someone if they behave
badly you don't need to say it up front
you you don't want an Ax Murderer either
but you're not saying that why are you
not saying that because you've been
burned in the past by someone who just
wanted a casual hookup with you so now
all you'd put in someone's mind is that
you've you're frustrated by the amount
of casual hookups that you've had to
have in the past because you wanted more
and they didn't like that's not that's
not what you want to put in someone's
mind is the things you're frustrated
with
in dating
so what she did was she she just very
elegantly said yeah I want a family my
kids are in my future
but I don't read that and go
it was because there's no Edge to it
it's the same I had a course years ago
and there were back years ago when I
started
I actually used to send people out for
the night women out for the night and
have them practice things I don't do
that anymore there's too many people in
it it was 2 000 people in an event we
can't send have them descend on the city
yeah yeah yeah but back when it was
small groups we actually like encouraged
people go out for the evening and try
this stuff
and it was really interesting there were
two single mums who came in the next day
and
one of them said how do I communicate to
someone that I am a single mum
it was a lot of like it felt heavy to
her
she saw it as baggage
there was another story where a woman
stood up and she goes so I was talking
to this guy
and I I liked him so I was started
initially like I immediately started
flirting with him and the first thing I
said when I spoke to him was your chin
dimple is really adorable it's not quite
as adorable as my daughter's cheek
dimples but it's pretty adorable
he had managed in the first line
to communicate that she was a mum
and have it be flirtatious
whereas someone else in the room was
going
how do I communicate
that I'm a single mother like she had
like Darth Vader waiting at home when a
guy was going to come over
that to me is fascinating and I think
dating profiles are a great place
they're a great kind of revealer of
what's our current mindset how playful
are we how lightly can we take ourselves
how lightly can we take our own baggage
like these are a lot can be communicated
in a few words that way we'll get back
to talking to Matthew in one second but
first I need to tell you
I need to tell you about out come on I
need to tell you about element element
is a science-backed electrolyte ratio of
sodium potassium and magnesium with none
of the junk no coloring no artificial
ingredients no gluten no fillers and no
BS they are the exclusive hydration
partner to Team USA weightlifting and
rely done by tons of Olympic athletes
and high performers all around the world
it'll help to regulate your appetite
it'll curb Cravings it'll help your
brain health everything about it I
absolutely adore it every single morning
it is the way that I start my day even
video guiding uses it and it tastes
fantastic that orange flavor is
absolutely phenomenal they also have a
no BS no questions asked refund policy
where if you do not like it for any
reason they will give you your money
back and you don't even need to return
the box that's how certain they are that
you'll love it head to drink lmnt.com
modern wisdom to get a free sample pack
of all eight flavors with your first box
that's drink
lmnt.com
modern wisdom
thank you very much for tuning in if you
enjoyed that then press here for a
selection of the best clips from the
podcast over the last few weeks